Gentlemen.
Congratulations, you've
made it to the second round.
In this round of
competition, you'll
be attaching handles
to your blades
to turn them into fully
functional weapons.
There's an entire pantry of
materials at your disposal
to use for your
handles, in addition to
an entire garbage can
full of junk we've
brought from the junkyard.
You will have to
incorporate at least
one piece of that junk,
visibly, into your handle's
construction.
Gotta keep up with the theme.
Just because your weapons
are made out of junk,
doesn't mean they need
to look like junk.
We want to see something
beautiful and functional.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your three-hour time starts now.
All right, all
right, all right.
Oh hell, it's go time.
So what do these
guys have to do
to make sure they meet
the requirements we've
given them in this challenge?
In many ways, they've
got to keep it simple
because two of our smiths
have a lot of metal
to move on their blades.
Right away, I
moved to the grinder.
I know I'm going to have a
good hour to an hour and a half
to get my blades
straightened out.
Nice two-inch band of
sparks coming off of there.
It's bright, too, man.
Moving metal.
Looks like the 4th
of July over there.
When I step up to the grinder
I've got quite a bit of stuff
to do.
It's a beast of a
knife and so I've
got to clean it up, lighten it
up, and get the balance right.
The first thing I want
to do is I want to start
looking at the materials.
It's overwhelming.
There's just so
much to choose from.
I find this nice
piece of dark wood.
We have to use a piece of this
junk and it has to be visible.
Plastic, huh?
So I'm looking through
this big barrel of junk,
and I find like
this bumper piece.
I'm thinking that's going
to make a great guard.
I'm straightening my
blade, but I haven't looked
at the junkyard stuff yet.
That's really what I need
to do in the next two
hours and 24 minutes.
[laughs]
I end up spending way too
much time on the grinder.
I'm thinking you're way
behind the 8-ball here, bubba.
I go to the handle
material trying
to find something that's
wide enough that's
going to cover my handle.
And it ended up
being warthog tooth
that's encased in acrylic.
What does Joe
have on his handle
that's from the garbage pile?
Nothing.
Nothing yet, right?
The only guy I think that
really has the junk material
figured out is Brandon.
[music playing]
At this point I got my guard
and my handle on the blade.
So I start trying to work
it, give it a basic shape.
[music playing]
While I'm waiting for my
epoxy to set up for my scales,
I'm trying to figure out how to
incorporate this piece of hinge
into this knife blade.
I grab a bumper cover, just a
urethane plastic bumper cover.
So I go to the band saw.
I'm fired up.
And I mean, I just ripped it
out just as fast as I could
go to make a bolster out of it.
A bolster's kind of a
front guard on the knife.
I'm going, OK, just relax.
We're going to do this and it's
going to be something great.
[music playing]
As I'm gluing the
handle up, everything's
fitting together great.
I'm-- I'm sweating the clock.
If I don't get something in the
handle that reflects anything
out of that barrel, I don't meet
the criteria for the challenge
and I'm out.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, drop your tools.
Going into
testing, I'm excited.
It's make or break
at this point.
And I just want to
see what it'll do.
I got it done.
If my handle holds up, I think
I'll have a real good chance.
Bladesmiths, I'll be testing
the strength and durability
of your blades by taking
each of your knives
and cutting into three coconuts.
Joe, you ready?
Yeah, let's see what it's got.
[music playing]
[sighs]
[knife hits]
[bleep]
Joe,
Yes, sir.
The width, the weight,
the curvature-- everything
feels really good about it.
There's no edge damage.
Overall, you did great.
Thank you.
Pete, you're up next.
You ready?
Yes.
[music playing]
There's a slight tremor
inside as Jason picks
it up and takes a look at it.
Deep breath.
[music playing]
[knife slams]
That's awesome.
Pete, got some really clean
cuts there with this knife.
Your edge geometry is perfect.
I was a little concerned
at how thin it was here.
But I mean, it comes
right down to sharp.
Well done.
Thank you.
Brandon, you're up.
You ready?
No, but I guess I
ain't got a choice, so--
All right.
[music playing]
I don't want to watch.
That's one.
[music playing]
[knife slams]
That's two.
[music playing]
[bleep]
My handle just splintered.
Oh, that hurt.
Brandon, you got a critical
failure on your handle.
It came apart on me.
Because of that, we won't
be able to continue testing.
I understand.
This type of wood
is very easily split
and you have a large pin there.
And everything that you
were trying to do to build
it up actually broke it down.
I guess I made a poor
choice in handle material.
Because of the
failure, Brandon's handle
will not continue with testing.
Brandon, your weapon
did not make the cut.
I have to ask you
to leave the forge.
[music playing]
I had this.
I know I did.
If that handle wouldn't of
broke, I would have had it.
I knew it.
I'm better than that.
[music playing]